ma situation et notre situation parce
que là aussi je parle en bon non mais je
représente quand même surpression notre
situation est un petit peu différente
madame la ministre vous parlez de triple
Pen tout à l'heure
nous c'est une double peine donc c'est
peut-être plus facile à résoudre archi
dans la souffrance mais grosse double
peine et je suis obligé de revenir un
petit peu en arrière puisque nous nous
avons été extrêmement impactés par la
crise covid ce qui était restaurateur
moi le cas de nos amis les boulangers et
tant mieux pour eux il y a aucune
jalousie dans ce que je dis mais c'est
une réalité nous on a énormément
souffert à titre d'exemple moi j'ai
perdu un an de chiffre d'affaires sur
trois ans disons que sur les l'année
2020 2021-2022 globalement c'est un an
de chiffre d'affaires qui est parti que
que je n'ai pas que ce n'est pas
engrangé je fais un peu plus d'un
million de chiffre d'affaires j'emploie
24 personnes disons en équivalent temps
plein sur deux sociétés différentes
puisque j'ai un hôtel un restaurant et
un centre équestre et donc l'ensemble et
PME de environ 20 voilà 26 27 personnes
environ sur l'ensemble de l'année
le covid qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
la première année on n'a pas eu d'aide
on peut dire que les aides elles étaient
très marginales la première année on a
eu le droit d'emprunter mais c'est comme
ça qu'on a passé le cap de la première
année donc on a eu ce fameux PGE dont
tout le monde parle alors je sais que
voilà c'est c'est
[Musique]
on parle toujours du pyjama on a un
petit peu marre d'entendre le péché le
seul problème c'est que c'est maintenant
que les choses se passent puisque c'est
maman on commence à le rembourser enfin
alors
il vaut mieux avoir véhicule le covid en
France qu'aux États-Unis
c'est vrai que il y a eu on a tout dit
sur le PGE entre autres entre autres
spécieux d'ailleurs que j'aime bien
appeler poison garanti par l'État pardon
de cette expression un peu un peu
vulgaire mais c'est un petit peu ça
c'est comme ça qu'on le ressent
on a eu on a cru espérer pendant la
campagne électorale et je fais pas de
politique en disant ça mais j'écoute
simplement que cette dette qui n'est pas
une dette d'exploitation c'est un
emprunt qu'on a dû prendre pour rester
trésorerie en fait ça ne sert pas dans
nos investissements ça n'est pas utile
ça ne diminue pas nos charges ça
n'augmente pas de chiffre d'affaires
c'est un crédit de trésorerie important
moi j'ai emprunté 300000 euros parce que
j'avais besoin de ces 300000 euros et
j'ai croqué les 300000 euros parce que
j'en ai eu besoin et aujourd'hui vous
voulez remboursez là alors moi je
commence à les rembourser ça fait 6 mois
que j'ai rembourse et je ne peux pas les
rembourser ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est ajouter les
problèmes dont on aime parler dont on
vient de parler exactement le problème
d'énergie il faut quand même considérer
si on pourrait être très simple
le remboursement du PGE c'est 6 points
de marge en 6 à 7 points de marche
environ en moyenne dans la profession à
25% de de de chiffre d'affaires
emprunter sous forme de PGE ça
représente sur trois ça représente 6 à
7%
la revalisation de la grille salariale
très importante il faut le faire je suis
il faut le dire il faut le dire il faut
le faire il faut le dire à ceux qui
disent que vous avez pas augmenté les
salaires parce que dans l'hôtellerie
vous avez beaucoup augmenté nous moi ça
va me coûter 9 l'augmentation c'est pas
15 % normalement c'est 15 %, moi c'est
l'augmentation va être de 9 % parce que
on était déjà un petit peu au dessus de
la grille donc
ça veut dire que ça va me coûter 6 % de
marge donc 6 pour le PGE 6 pour
l'augmentation de salaire et à cela je
rajoute l'énergie donc les DF moi en ce
qui me concerne je suis beaucoup plus
chanceux que mon confrère boulanger
puisque mon augmentation mon coefficient
n'est que de 4 non combien de temps je
vais passer de 21000 à
72000 donc si 72000
j'ai j'ai j'ai 70
000 euros de remboursement annuel de PGE
et j'ai 70000 euros d'augmentation
d'électricité parce que on ne parle que
de l'électricité mais j'ai aussi du gaz
je suis choqué au gaz et le gaz il est
doublé c'est coefficient de donc je
passe de le gaz de 13000 à 26000 euros
donc comment dans une dans un commerce
dans lequel on gagne très peu d'argent
on est d'accord moi je suis en province
je suis à la campagne je suis dans le
département de l'Allier c'est
merveilleux c'est très beau et cetera
mais je suis pas ni dans une zone
je suis pas sur la Côte d'Azur je suis
pas dans une station de montagne je suis
comme beaucoup de mes confrères dans
dans le tiroir dans dans le tourisme
vert avec une forte saisonnalité et bien
je je gagne peut-être deux trois pour
cent les bonnes années de 3 % de marge à
peu près ça le standard de 3% de marge
là il faut que je sorte 18% de marge je
peux pas je ne peux pas donc je suis
confronté à une impossibilité et je ne
sais pas ce qui va se passer madame la
ministre donc là il va se passer quoi
pour vous moi je d'abord le PGE pour
l'instant je rembourser jusqu'à présent
donc j'ai déjà remboursé 40000 euros de
PGE donc c'est 40000 € que je n'ai pas
dans mes caisses au passage j'ai
emprunté à titre personnel 40000 euros
pour remettre dans mon entreprise donc
finalement c'est moi mes prêts
personnels qui renvoie le PG ce qui est
ce qui est insensé enfin ça n'a plus de
sens on est dans une dans une sorte
d'économie qui est juste complètement
ubuesque décalé aujourd'hui quand vous
allez vous en sortir vous allez voir
alors ben écoutez on a il y a des
dispositifs quand même un ami je va
certainement le dire on peut négocier
c'est ce qu'on appelle les médiations
mais la médiation c'est c'est un piège
pardon de le dire
je suis obligé de négocier c'est-à-dire
que il va falloir que je trouve c'est
gagner du temps pour mettre autour de la
table le la Banque de France les les
banques auxquelles j'ai souscrit des
emprunts donc en partie mon PGE et puis
mes fournisseurs mais auprès de qui je
n'ai personnellement aucune dette donc
mes seules dettes c'est vis-à-vis des
banques il va falloir qu'on se mette
d'accord pour
avant de raisonner l'analyse je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de vous poser la question
pourquoi pourquoi doit-on rembourser ce
PGE pourquoi ma question vous suffirait
de supprimer le PSG déjà pour sauver ces
gens là vous avez entendu pour les
banques vous l'avez dit ce que vous avez
entendu lors de l'élection président
de d'Emmanuel Macron et et et Marine Le
Pen la remontée du du PGE dans les quasi
fonds propres
avaient été avancé
il y a eu un dépôt de bois à antérieur à
ça il y avait un dépôt de loi qui avait
été fait par l'UDI en une semaine
parce que c'est possible ça
alors déjà j'ai à coeur de rappeler que
tout est toujours possible donc après
c'est les choix politiques et des
décisions politiques
le PGE c'est à peu un peu plus de 150
milliards d'euros
ce qui est important que je partage avec
vous sans être trop casse-pied c'est que
la situation
économique du monde elle a changé entre
2000 et 2023 vous êtes des chefs
d'entreprise vous êtes des particuliers
vous savez ce que c'est un taux
d'intérêt quand vous achetez une voiture
quand vous achetez vous rénovez une
boulangerie les taux d'intérêt quand on
a fait les PGE ils étaient négatifs les
taux d'intérêt ce soir on se parle ils
ont dépassé les 3% entre Noël et le
Jourdain c'est-à-dire que quand on prend
1000 euros ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
aujourd'hui que ça te coûtait en 2020
vous avez dit quelque chose auquel je
suis très sensible je le redis j'ai été
plus entrepreneur que le ministre on est
dans un système non mais je vous
garantis que je réponds aux questions
moi donc le PG je vais répondre pourquoi
pourquoi parce que 150 milliards de
dettes aujourd'hui avec des taux
d'intérêt comme on les a et merci de me
relancer ce serait irresponsable et je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que vous
me diriez à ce moment-là dans deux trois
ans madame Grégoire vous avez fait
n'importe quoi la dette est là explosé
et on est sorti des clous du déficit
totalement nos taux d'intérêt regardez
la Grande-Bretagne on bondit alors là
pour aller réemprunter avec des taux à
6% c'est costaud et surtout vous me
diriez en gros vous avez dilapidé notre
argent et quand il y a des dettes c'est
valable pour l'État aussi il y a qu'un
moyen de la remonter c'est les impôts et
si les impôts des entreprises ou les
impôts des particuliers